Elizabeth two percent of what happens in
the dark web is actually illegal but
today we're gonna read true crime
stories that involved the dark web
British model kidnapped for own like
this British model kidnapped for dark
web auction a 20 year old British model
was kidnapped in Milan Italy to be
auctioned off on a pornographic website
on the dark web
the motto who has not been named what's
assaulted drugged handcuffed and stuck
in a travel bag the suspect allegedly
said that he was operating on behalf of
the black death group an organization
involved in illegal trafficking on the
dark web yeah that's really [ __ ] up
that's terrifying oh this is terrifying
yeah I see this is why the dark web is
called that this is terrible and it's
really scary I mean obviously human
slavery and human trafficking is a big
thing it's all over the world
there you go this happens in the dark
web but I feel like this also happens in
real life and it's just really shitty to
actually see it written and get details
on stuff like that because those are
things that I'd rather not know but at
the end of the day we don't know about
them that how are we gonna do anything
about them man buys grenades on the dark
web gets sentenced to life in prison
Paul still Otto using the name cocaine
King two four seven contacted a seller
asking if advertised hand grenades could
be delivered to the UK the total cost of
the grenades was three hundred and
seventy dollars which still auto paid in
bitcoins according to the NCAA he had
sent an image of an explosive to an
associate asking if I had shrapnel will
it do a hole in a house
what does he
need to blow up I've opened a door of
questions I guess it's the dark web so
maybe you trust people but if I'm gonna
buy grenades I'm not gonna
I guess I'd meet someone in person
backtrack I'm not gonna buy grenades
don't buy grenades you start wondering
if like was there kids in this house
why did cocaine King 247 have beef with
these people there's no reason you need
a grenade if you're just a normal human
if you're just a regular good human
don't be shopping for grenades a church
elders Ashley Madison Affairs led him to
the dark web and murder police say on
the dark web hackers had cracked into
basa mafia a website that claimed
affiliation with Albanian organized
crime and offered to arrange beatings
and assassinations for a price holy [ __ ]
as investigators sifted through the
material they zeroed in on an exchange
between a user called Dog Day God who
they determined was trying to arrange
the murder of a woman named Amy Alwine
in November 2016 Amy Owen was discovered
dead and within months they would allege
Stephen Alwine was actually they dog was
that her husband Stephen Owen was
actually dog day God he had killed his
wife after they said mafia failed to
come through what a plot twist okay
the dark web actually was like nah I'm
not gonna do this see this is proof that
the dark web is really just a tool for
all this people that are sick out here
trying to do crazy [ __ ] because like the
dark web didn't actually do what he
wanted so he did it you know what
Stephen I won you get what you deserve
Texas man arrested after searching dark
web for girl to murder and eat oh man
what are you doing barter wrote a post
on the dark web looking for someone to
help him commit necrophilia and
cannibalism and to contact him an
undercover officer intercepted barters
communication and when he contacted
barter the suspect allegedly asked how
old is your daughter can we kill her
this is gross
don't like it this is disgust
this is a horrible man not in the dark
web not in the light web not in real
life you should never do this and if you
feel like wanting to do this you should
get help this is crazy
well there's a lot of stuff available on
on the Internet a bad man
another bad man if they don't go to the
dark web they're still thinking it so I
think the dark web is if anything's like
a tool for us to see what crazy [ __ ]
people are actually wanting to do mother
convicted of selling son to pedophiles
on dark web no German mother and her
partner were convicted in jail Tuesday
for repeatedly raping the woman's young
son now 10 and selling him to men on the
darknet the couple allowed four other
men to sexually abuse a boy among them a
German soldier a Swiss man and a
Spaniard who admitted paying a couple
eleven thousand five hundred and sixty
u.s. dollars to rape the boy multiple
times jesus [ __ ] christ
a ten-year-old that's not good okay
and it was filmed this is really [ __ ]
up stuff some of the other ones were
like one person tried to do this one
person did that or maybe like the Mafia
but like this is like five five
different parties coming together and
agreeing upon doing this like I I don't
know what else to say about this yeah I
don't think I have I know the dark web
can't offer things that aren't as crazy
as this but the fact that like all this
crazy [ __ ] is on there too it makes you
wonder if like we need it you know the
Internet is such a it was such a great
invention it's such a creative place and
it's also a very terrifying place where
some really fucked-up [ __ ] can happen I
don't want to go there I don't like it
you know it's a bad place bad place I
don't care for it I'm gonna stay -
Google Chrome Google Chrome and Yahoo
when I'm feeling a little spicy
[Music]